so we begin with an article on cnn.com
about christy gnome who has signed some
executive orders dealing with the boys
in girls sports issue but she still
refuses to sign
legislation but instead she's she's
doing executive orders the article talks
about that but then it gets to the
kicker
we'll read here it says south dakota's
republican governor christie gnome
banned transgender girls and women from
competing
on women's sports teams at public high
schools and colleges via a pair of
executive orders
issued on monday of course what what she
actually banned was
boys playing in girls teams
the move came after gnome angered
conservatives by killing a bill that
would have created a similar prohibition
in a news release explaining her veto at
the time noam cited her
concern that the bill would take the
state's colleges and universities out of
compliance with national rules so we
know about that she's worried that uh
the the naacp would would punish
the state of south dakota the naacp
would get really mad
and and punish them if uh if she tried
to ins
put this if this ban was put in place
and it applied to colleges and she
didn't want to make the naacp mad
and get punished by them or rather the
ncaa i should say she doesn't want to
get she doesn't want to make them mad
get punished by them
so um she decided to do the executive
orders instead
now here we get to the kicker it says
though the two executive orders
signed by gnome do not explicitly
mention transgender athletes
they reference the supposed harms of the
participation of
quote males in women's athletics and
they put quotes around males
yeah quote unquote well we don't need
the quotes there that we are talking
about actual males
it says an echo of the transphobic claim
cited in other similar legislative
initiatives
that transgender women are not women
the orders also reference biological sex
a disputed term
that refers to the sex as listed on
students original birth certificates
and then here we go here it's not
possible to know a person's gender
identity at birth
and there is no consensus criteria for
assigning sex
at birth there is no consensus
criteria for assigning sex at birth
now your the first part of that sentence
is right
that there is no way to know a baby's
gender identity
because that's a made-up concept gender
identity doesn't exist
kids have to be indoctrinated into
believing in this thing called gender
identity
babies haven't been indoctrinated yet so
for them gender identity doesn't exist
that's true
the rest of it though is where we go
wildly off the rails
there's there's no consensus think about
the claim here okay
think about the claim here this is in a
news article
this is not an editorial a cnn news
article
saying there's no consensus criteria for
figuring out the sex of a child
they're not just saying that technically
we we we can't really know the sex now
that would be totally wrong also
they're claiming that there's no
consensus criteria yes there
is so this is wrong
horribly ridiculously wrong on two
levels
not only can we obviously tell the sex
of a child
most of the time all you got to do is
look between the legs
but there is clearly a consensus
criteria
every child birth that happens
on earth everywhere and it has been this
case since the beginning of
of humanity the criteria has been
let's look at the at the um
let's look at the reproductive organs on
the child
that's that's been the criteria
that's what hospitals do i have been
been there for the the births of four
children
that's that's the way it goes
so even if you want to claim that we
can't know the sex or that
the sex of a child is fluid again all
that obviously totally wrong
you would have to you would think at
least admit that there is right now a
consensus criteria
if you want to say that that criteria
doesn't work or whatever
then then fine make that case
but to deny that the criteria even
exists at all
well this is what we get from the left
obviously they can they will just
simply wave their hand and
say that that truth that like this isn't
happening
you you thought that that was happening
you thought that in every hospital
in the world when a baby is born they
look between the legs and and and figure
out what the sex is
they don't assign it by the way there's
no assignment happening
the doctor isn't looking and saying okay
this one's going to be a boy
then you just just stamp the word boy on
its head that's not the way it works
but they are but that is what how
they're determining it and the left says
no that's not
that's not happening what you think
you're saying you're not seeing
how about these are the pro-science
people remember that
these are these are the people who feel
entitled
feel like they're in a position where
they can accuse other people of being
anti-science
right well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content